just a strong Bach everything just
flew apart and just ran
out of the house Yes Why were
we just coming And here it is already
all in pieces It was very scary
now I don’t even know what to
do There is no festive mood at all but we
will hold on We will somehow celebrate anyway There
is
no excuse for them  they are not people,
they are some kind of animals,
but you are standing,
let's clean up, let's clean the windows, remove the film and everything will be fine
and we will live free in Ukraine, it's
clear that the
explosion was very strong and after that the
windows flew out Well, they started falling like that
after that, the shrapnel
flew like that, the
war continues for eight  years, but now it has
reached a new terrorist level
with cynical silence. I believe that the
international community, which is even afraid of
recognizing them as terrorists and recognizes them as
sponsors of terrorism, does
absolutely whatever they want